[Music]
the automobile it can outrun trains make
you look like a badass and can even swim
and it's not surprising that it's
marriage with movies has been a
celebrated with auto enthusiasts and
film buffs alike taking part in all the
action there have been some creative
takes on the modified cars from our
favorite films but behind the masks
merchandising and real-life replicas the
car has played as big a role as the
characters behind the wheel as the car
community's popularity exploded in size
the film industry took notice for the
dragsters that were featured in such
classics as George Lucas's American
Graffiti - the muscle of the General Lee
in Dukes of Hazzard the automotive and
film industry had found each other when
it comes to classics we have to discuss
the fastback Mustang in Steve McQueen's
bollock Frank bullets car is a 1968 Ford
Mustang 390 GT fastback as the 80s
rolled around we were introduced to the
DeLorean and as doc pol doubt of the car
at Pine Hills Mall and back to the
future we were enamored with its
stainless steel Bonnie glowing flux
capacitor and futuristic gauges atop the
dash America was hooked just overnight
the DeLorean dmc-12 would go from
junkyard accessory to cult collectable
and what made the DeLorean from Back to
the Future special were the
modifications the plutonium powered
engine the rapid fire of the flux
capacitor and of course hitting 88 miles
per hour could propel you backward
Orville
and times iconic cards would appear in
the years following with the reinvention
of the Batmobile and Tim Burton's take
on the story we were witnesses to what
limits the film industry was willing to
soar past to innovate the car
however the Batmobile would evolve along
with the change in directors most
notably once Christopher Nolan's Batman
came around in 2005 and with his
franchise reboot came the tumbler but
not for the meet the tumbler featured a
more fortified base which boasted nearly
15 feet in length other features
included a 500 horsepower engine twin
firing machine guns and the option for
the front wheels to be ejected to form
the Batpod to further show the deaths
car fans and film buffs would go to a
man recently manufactured a real-life
replica of the tumbler and has put it up
for sale with a whopping price tag of 1
million dollars
as far as auto innovations and movies go
the James Bond series has successfully
rolled out a bevy of cars go along with
its collection of movies from a car that
can transform into a sub and fire under
water to the Aston Martin db5 the
franchise's has been a launching
promotional pad for luxury automakers to
debut and showcase new models Oh James
wrong the same can be said for the
transformer franchise which reinvade the
Camaro after a seven-year hiatus when it
comes down to a more modern take on the
car no franchise has recently addressed
the needs of fans more than the Fast and
Furious franchise from the mark 4 Supra
RZ Paul Walker drives in the first film
with an astounding twin-turbocharged 544
horsepower engine featuring NAS - the
skyline gt-r r34 which first makes its
appearance in
the skyline makes subsequent returns in
latter films as well with Brian driving
it in a race with Dom the film franchise
heavily rolled off the influence of
imported cars these tuners have had lots
of success on screen because of the
franchise's ability to appeal to a
younger crop of car fanatics so where do
we go from here
with the rapid advancement of Technology
in both the filmmaking and automotive
industry it will be interesting to see
what the next big steps are to the two
and with the upcoming Need for Speed
film already showcasing a variety of
supercars
such as the Koenigsegg Agera R the
Lamborghini Sesto Elemento and the
McLaren p1 it seems as though car fans
are once again in good hands
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]